thank you members can I ask you you
remain standing please for a moment I'd
like to introduce Dr Roy Lodge MBA beg
you pardon Dr Roy Reverend lar MBE to
lead in the thought for the
day thank you madam
chair thank you madam chair and good
afternoon to counc councelors officers
and also members of the
public no doubt many of us will shortly
be jooy enjoying um a drink in our local
hosery which Drew my attention to a a
paper cutting that I thought would be of
interest to you that uh an incident that
took place um several years ago and has
a relevance for the um importance of of
prayer and what we make of Prayer
a man got planning permission to open
the first Pub in the small mining
Village in the valley in South
Wales the members of the local Chapel
were so strongly opposed to having a
place in their Community selling alcohol
that they began to pray that God would
intervene a few days before the pub was
due to open lightning struck the
building and it burned to the
ground the people of the chapel were
surprised but abundantly thrilled to
bits until they received a legal
notification that the landlord was going
to sue
them he held that their prayers were
responsible for the destruction of the
pub in a very strongly worded
disposition the deacons of the chapel
denied absolutely any
responsibility at the end of the court
hearing the judge rather Ry
remarked at this point I am not really I
am really not sure what my decision will
be but this appears to be the
situation the owner of the pub clearly
believes in the power of prayer and the
people from the chapel quite obviously
don't well the lesson that we can gather
and learn from this is that before we
invoke the power of God
that we must be sure that we are
prepared to live with the results with
that in mind let us
pray oh god of
wisdom Grant to counselors in all their
deliberations a just motive clear
judgment and consistent thought that
they may remain Servants of the truth by
keeping their integrity in their search
for the common good amen
amen thank you thank you thank you very
much for
that I'll see you soon thank
you right then members just wait for the
chaplain to
leave
I now declare this meeting open please
be
seated right welcome to this four
council
meeting today item one on the agenda is
apologies for absence uh David are there
any apologies for absence please thank
you chairman yeah we have apologies
receiv received from councel bromage
councel Kohl's councelor hencher sarapin
and councelor scora thank
you thank you very much sorry I think C
only say uh uh yes Council hoggins I've
also received notice from councelor
Darren pton who will be late to this
meeting and he sends his apologies for
that thank you
counselor um item two on the agenda uh
Declarations of interest do any members
or officers have any Declarations of
interest on items on the
agenda uh councelor perella
please yes so um item8 review of polling
districts and polling places in relation
to the next general election I'm the
liberal Democrat parliamentary candidate
for straford donon constituency thank
you very much councelor perella uh
can I is there any other declarations Mr
bu David counselor no not counselor
whoever thank you chairman uh chair
sorry on behalf of all staff I'd like to
declare an interest in relation to the
staff strategy report it's not our DPI
but just as another vegetable interest
thank
you thank you are there any other
Declarations of Interest
please okay thank you very much um item
three on the agenda minutes can I please
have a proposer and a seconder for the
minutes of the meeting held on the 16th
of October
2023 proposer thank you councelor juned
seconder thank you councelor
Johnson all in agreement for the
minutes all happy thank you very
much excuse me item four
announcements so these
are some of the events I have attended
since the last
meeting I couldn't put them all here we
would be here until next week and not
one of us wants to hear hear all of that
however um just a few the highlights I
attending the Remembrance Day Parade in
Stratford with others I laid the two
wreaths on both World War I and World
War II though my husband did have to
help me with the World War II Memorial
due to the steps leading up to
it uh councelor fraggy also has attended
um appointments on my be on our behalf
she attended the side by-side th
production on behalf of the
council thank you um I attended the 35
years of world AIDS day in addon it was
incredibly moving um with the candlelit
vigil
outside um and also was thrilled to hear
the scientists and the doctors speak
that they are on track to eradicate HIV
and AIDS by
2030 um that I think is something that
most certainly deserves
recognition um councelor fine in fagley
also attended the remembering lives lost
and injured on our roads in warshire
service and has also attended the cor
Society um also and I thank you very
much for your support counselors in that
I've been to St Mary's Church in Warick
for the Lord left tenant Advent Service
they also had the Christmas tree walk
which was wonderful to
see and again counselors Jenny and E
fagley attended The Rock Church annual
toy offering which happened to be on the
same
day um obviously there's more items with
attending agms and meetings across the
whole of the
district um and everything I've done in
the past 4 days
which will come to the next council
meeting thank
you
um sorry I now invite the leader Council
councelor Susan GED to make any
announcements um just to let you know
some of the things that I've also been
involved with I've continued to attend
the West Midlands combined Authority
board um I attended a local government
Finance Minister we we uh webinar with
the minister um I attended the staff
induction uh and gave a presentation an
ecap presentation to churches together
uh concerning my
portfolio um a couple also attended an
excellent Services fair and attended the
leaders program that the LGA had puts on
and I spent two days at War University
on that program just a couple of things
that have occurred since the last
Council that I would like to the council
to take on board one was we've had a
considerable amount of floods both River
and uh surface water drainage uh
flooding I have asked for a meeting to
be convened with the environment agency
warshire County Council and others to
look at resilience and flood prevention
and what is planned for the future and
I've also had a been consulted about the
uh fire service consultation uh it's
been issued and I have expressed my wish
that warer County Council fire service
officers should be invited to come to a
committee and I would assume that this
would be an overview and scrutiny
committee to brief all counselors before
our response is submitted so those are
things that I I have been involved in um
since the last council meeting thank
you thank you leader um could I please
now invite the chief executive David
bookland to make any announcements thank
you chair um I got four items first one
relates to item 14 on the agenda this
afternoon it talks about the
extraordinary meeting of the audit and
standards committee which was held
earlier
today when the agenda was published we
thought there was going to be a
recommendation from the audit and
standards committee to council there
wasn't any need for a recommendation to
council and therefore that item can be
withdrawn however I can report that at
the meeting this morning um a working
group was established in relation to the
review of outside bodies and it was also
agreed to undertake a constitution in
relation to the document becoming more
gender neutral so that was they were
both discussed it at the audit and
standards committee this morning any
final recommendations on either of those
items will come to the council for full
debate just want to also mention that in
consultation with the leader the council
has agreed to the local government
Association peer review the last fall
review was undertaken in 2017 with a
followup in
2019 it is expected that with the
establishment of the office for local
government the process will be more
challenging than has been in the past
the review will be undertaken between
the 4th and the 6th of March
2024 thank you to the 32 of you who have
already responded to the survey in
relation to the proposed start times for
Council meetings the the further nine
that haven't responded I I do know who
you are but if you if you could respond
that that that would be massively
helpful and and and assist the process
and then lastly I just wanted to say
Matthew thank you to to staff it has
been a really challenging year for
everybody but they've always perform
their duties far above what I could
reasonably expect so I'd like to thank
staff particularly thank you
chair thank you very much for
that right then counselors um item five
public
participation in accordance with the
council's Constitution questions may
only be asked when received by the head
of paid service two clear days before
the day of the
meeting we have received one question
from the public Miss price
could you please approach the
table hello welcome to council you may
ask one supplementary question and
you'll have three minutes to
speak let us know when you're ready to
start that okay so um I'm quite
confident but I can see that for many
people this might be quite intimidating
actually to come and address you but I'm
going to read my question which is I
think the point yes I do that okay
councelor juned um you asserted that the
new regime wants people to know will be
a listening Council to restore trust in
local democracy y meanwhile Extinction
Rebellion which I'm here representing
has reorientated towards engagement with
local groups and parties and has a
long-standing desire for a culture of
particip ipation fairness and
transparency so encouraged by the
council's intention Stratford XR
organized an informal popup people's
assembly on B bankr Gardens that sort
people's views on what might be done to
make statford and District
Greener we received a positive response
with several suggestions for Town and
District the suggestions were put in a
survey to find out how people might
prioritize the ideas that were
identified and counselors will be
receiving written feedback about that in
due course but actually why I want to
talk to you today um was what was most
striking was the enthusiasm of local
people for active involvement in
decision- making on this topic we
appreciate you have a published
Community engagement plan but it's
questionable whether this is effective
in addition we can put a question to you
directly in this way but as I've said
maybe it's intimidating but um we're
Limited to 3 minutes and there's a
supplementary question but we're not
really engaging with each other so
there's also sadly the regular ofan that
we hear from the public which is what's
the point in engaging the council they
do what they want
anyway so why I while I know many
counselors are approachable I've meet
many of you on a regular basis and I
know you meet other members of the
public regularly but it's not the same
as a collective
cross-party regular formal and trans
transparent public
engagement so we're not seeking
commitment to a singular event or to a
gimmick but to sustained and early
public involvement embedded in the
appropriate decision-making processes of
the
council this early involvement would
allow for public knowledge and
understanding to be considered in
decision making while at the same time
time allowing the electorate to
understand the reasons for those
decisions so questions have been asked
in Council I believe and also through
the media about the cost of such
consultation but I would argue that
inadequate public engagement is more
costly I'm sure if you're kind of honest
with yourselves you'll have examples of
that and certainly I know of a few which
I've written about but so personally
having lived in Stratford for over 20
years this is the first time I've
submitted a question because I want to
believe in the intention of the newly
elected regime So speaking on behalf of
an Alliance of environmental groups I
ask
this in line with the council's
commitment to addressing the climate
emergency and establishing a green
environment and its declared investment
in strong active communities we would
like to know what plans there are for a
formal and regular in-person citizens
assembly or the like to identify and
action green
priorities will local environmental
groups be involved invited to
participate alongside counselors and
officers and what is the time scale for
the initiation of these thank you for
your
attention thank you very much indeed for
coming along uh I do appreciate uh we
met at
the I gave an eoch chat uh presentation
to churches together uh in which I
expressed the uh the the the view that
communities had to be part of the
process and it's that is a that has been
supported by many many people within the
the sphere that the academic and
scientific and other sphere that I I
work in the climate change committee for
example said that things would not
change unless people were fully engaged
uh we as well as the in the response
that I put there that uh we will explore
I the district council statford District
Council the mor District Council worked
recently on a project for which we had
outside funding
uh which was to work out how we could
best engage with communities and we
worked with parish councils and other
partners on ways forward uh that we
there were some outside bodies came in
to give us some advice so I really do
thank you for your question uh we do
aspire to be a listening Council and
recognize the mean the full meaning of
uh public engagement it should play a
part in strong decision making and I
certainly welcome that uh that intention
we do need an ongoing meaningful
dialogue I was originally part of an
instigated the local Agenda 21 in this
Council where we did have that kind of
engagement on a regular Bas basis with
quite a few other community groups so I
do know that uh is something that does
work we're actively involved with town
and Parish councils we need to do more
and look going forward we're about to
launch a community climate change fund
as well to promote and support count the
communities that we've got uh
initiatives within the district that
will help to uh address climate change
we'll continue to build up the work of
the of the climate change panel I've
already asked the uh question to the
officers about the climate change panel
and the public participation part of
that climate change panel as to whether
it's working right uh whether it needs
to be rethought through as to how we
engage
um the idea of a citizen assembly is
definitely interesting and I'm happy to
consider this we you said the assembly
all the like we we we will have to and I
would like to be able to engage on
exactly the format of that uh and we
welcome the chance to have an ongoing
public engagement in on this so thank
you very much indeed for putting your
question and I do hope that we get the
chance to talk more as we go forward
thank you do I get a supplementary you
do when do we
start um it would be after the some
after the Christmas holidays okay but I
would ask the climate change officer to
start working up something after the the
Christmas holidays are over and we will
be in touch that's lovely otherwise I'll
see you next time thank you thank you
very much for coming to ask your
question and have a have a great break
and happy Christmas and New Year to
you right thank you uh thank you for
that right item six on the agenda the
independent rumination p panel item six
on the agenda has been withdrawn coun uh
Mr Buckland sorry you're getting El what
can I say could you please explain the
reasons uh thank you chairman and
hopefully Council has received the email
that I circulated last Tuesday
explaining that the report as published
does contain an error from the IRP um
it's acknowledged that that report
specifically in relation to the trans um
the travel allowance section is
incorrect I've got a session lined up
with the chair of the IRP tomorrow
afternoon and we're hoping that it can
be that item can be brought back to
Council in February for consideration
but I do apologize that there was that
era in the report thank
you thank you death that item's just
been withdrawn okay um item
seven procedure and appointment of
Parish Town Council
Representatives um could I please call
on councelor rice to introduced this
report as chairman of the audit and
standards committee thank you thank you
chair um a meeting of the audit and
standards committee was held on the 13th
of no November um Committee of which I
chair and the following item was
considered and referred to
council um it was recommended to council
uh that the terms of the current Parish
Town Council Representatives be extended
until March uh 2024 to enable the
procedure for an appointment of such
representatives to be
reviewed uh secondly that the procedure
for the appointment of Parish Town
Council Representatives be reviewed the
wording of which to be delegated to
officers in consultation with the
chairman that is me of the audit and
standards committee with a view to an
appointments procedure to commence from
the 1 of April next year and thirdly
that a clearly defined function to
oversee the appointments of Parish Town
Council Representatives be incorporated
into the terms of reference for the
audit and standards committee the
wording of which to be delegated to the
monitoring
officer in consultation with the chair
of the
committee thank
you uh thank you councelor rice can I
just call for a second for that please
thank you
councilor are there any MERS thank you
pardon would you you like to Second it
then yes I'm happy to Second it chair
thank you thank you I do apologize
um are there any members who wish to
speak on this on this matter
please um councelor perala
please thank you chair as Parish Council
Champion I'd like to thank our current
parish and Town Council representatives
for staying on while the review on the
appointment procedure is
undertaken thank
you thank you councelor perella
councilor wol
please no okay that's
fine do any other members wish to speak
on this
matter okay I have a proposer and I have
a seconder are we all
agreed okay thank you that the
recommendations note in report are
approved thank you very
much um item eight on the agenda review
of the polling districts and polling
places this is again from the audit and
standards committee on the 13th of
November can I please invite Council rce
again to introduce the report as
chairman of this committee yes uh thank
you chair we had a very busy meeting
obviously on the 3rd 13th of November um
a much shorter recommendation to council
that the polling review schedule as set
out in appendix one to the Agenda Report
be
approved subject to the uh proposed
amendments thank
you thank you councilor rice could I
have a second for that please councelor
fragile thank you very
much okay thank you councelor frag uh
yes you may speak at the end um this
will be debated are there any members
who wish to speak on this matter
please okay thank you councelor fley
would you wish to speak now on this or
are you no it is obviously unnecessary
thank
you thank you very much um I have a
proposer I have a seconder um are we all
agreed
counselors okay thank you very
much the recommendations noted in the
report are
approved um item nine on the agenda the
calendar of
meetings uh this is also from the audit
and standards committee on the 13th of
November I invite councilor rice to
introduce his report as chairman of that
committee thank you chair my
physiotherapist will be very pleased
with his agenda
um also on the 13th of November uh we
recommended to council that the calendar
of meetings as amended for
2425 be agreed and that the calendar of
meetings as amended for
2526 be approved on the basis that these
are provisional dates to help with
formal planning a forward planning thank
you thank you councilor rise can I I
have a seconder for this please uh
councilor Stander thank you very much
thank you chair I'm happy to second
that thank you um would any members like
to speak on this
please oh you are playing nice today
this is quite good
um I have a proposer I have a second
there are we all in agreement that this
be
recommended thank you very
much item 10 on the agenda is the minute
from the employment committee meeting on
the 28th of November regarding the staff
strategy I invite councilor Johnson
please to introduce the report as
chairman of that
committee thank you chair could I
commend the staff's strategy to the
council and propose the two resolutions
on page
58 be
agreed
the strategy I'd like to thank all the
staff who have involved in preparing the
strategy there's been a a survey of
Staff a series of focus groups um the
strategy deals with the culture of the
organization how it feels to work for
the council to create a positive culture
and working environment where staff are
confident at work feel valued and have a
sense of belonging the ambition is to be
the employer of choice attract new and
retaining current
staff the strategy was discussed at the
last meeting of the staff and members
group The Joint negotiating and
consultation group and was approved
unanimously at the employment committee
on the 28th of November though we're
proposing that this is delegated to the
chief executive the action plan will be
monitored by the employment committee
twice a year can I move the two
recommendations on page 58 to be adopted
by the
Council thank you counselor could I have
a second over that please second uh
thank you councelor juned are there any
members who wish to speak on this please
uh councelor Wy
hoggins yes we're heartened indeed to
note the um that we're now going to look
at a new Apprentice scheme for for the
council um we have amongst us uh dear
Lauren Stanley here who I can tell you
was a very high caliber Apprentice uh
working for this within this Council a
few years ago not only that but uh not
only is Lauren a conservative but she
was also awarded Apprentice of the year
so we are delighted indeed that she's
sitting here amongst us today but also
she's an excellent example of what a
really robust and exciting opportunity
uh the apprentices scheme can do for
statford District Council thank you very
much indeed and thank you Lauren for
your High Caliber work that you do for
all of us thank
you thank you for that um any other
members who would L to speak uh
councelor Harvey
please thank you chairperson um this is
a welcome document and i' to follow upon
Council W hoggins his remarks uh to see
greater emphasis being placed on uh
growing our own uh given the age profile
of of the organization that's very
heartening I am concerned however with
uh paragraph
5.2.1 that this ambitious program is
going to be undertaken within current
existing
resources could I encourage uh the
administration to ensure that the The
Authority has all the resources that it
needs in order to be to deliver this
strategy because I think it would be
money well invested and I'll look
forward to seeing how that pledge is
fulfilled in the budget proposals when
we receive them thank you
thank you uh
counselor are there any other the
members who wish to speak on this
matter well I have a proposer I have a
seconder all in favor
please sorry members can I just ask that
you make it obvious if you're putting
your hands up please all in favor please
that's carried thank you that is carried
thank you very much
item 11 on the agenda
please minute from the cabinet meeting
on the 4th of
December uh regarding the council plan
can I please introduce councelor Jun Ed
the leader to lead on this
item can I first of all start by saying
thank you to everybody that took part in
input to the council plan
that was not only counselors it was not
only members of Staff it was members of
the community and part our partners as
well all of whom uh took part in the
consultation we were very hardened by
the the number of responses we got back
and some of the comments that we've got
back to the proposed council plan the
the officers have also put forward a
considerable amount of background
statistics uh that that back up the the
aims of the C plan and I do thank them
for doing that those those statistics
will be very very useful as we move
forward in the next year so the period
of the council's current plan has ended
and then this is the new plan that will
take us forward it will set the overall
direction for the authority and be a
strategic guiding document to meet the
Ambitions of the council over this
period of the next four years it is it
it has had a considerable amount of
input as I mentioned and those are all
lot of the comments that were given to
us we have taken on board as they were
made I would like to be able to move
that that this is accepted as a council
plan and as a strategic document to
formulate the action plan for the
council for the next four years I move
the the uh uh the plan thank
you thank you leader um can I call for a
second
please uh councilor rock thank you thank
you I'll second the recommendation to
the document thank
you are you reserving your right to
speak at the end councelor Rock uh yes
thank you for reminding me
chair you're welcome
um and are there any members who wish to
speak on this members in the same way as
as I called for the vote to be obvious
can I please have request that you make
it obvious if you wish to speak
thank you councelor w
hoggins thank
you our Inc incredulity over the
inadequacies are now of this plan and
now obvious to all those that the
libdems try to engage with it the leader
Drew attention at the meeting of the
cabinet on the 4th of December to the
encouragement she took from the level of
response that had been generated through
the consultation exercise in relation to
the plan now before us I note however
that the 439 responses or generated by
this plan is less than 2third of the 669
responses generated when the proposed
2019 to 23 plan was a subject of
consultation similarly I note that in
passing of course that the 2019 to 23
council plan was passed by the council
in October
2019 two months ahead of the timetable
adopted this time around but speed of
action is not everything it's the
quality of the plan that is the measure
of whether it's worth supporting
so what do I think of the quality of
this plan well this council plan should
demonstrate that the lib dem's own
leadership and decision making is of a
caliber fit to hold office this plan
will serve as is as an an excellent
example of why they are not a new course
strategy is not mentioned as a priority
for the new Administration plan and it
has already decided as part
of some time ago that the consequences
of its own in experience that the the
core strategy is now going to be delayed
by two years apparently you are now
going to bring detailed action plans for
each priority to Cabinet in March 2024
so by the time these are written and
approved you will have wasted nearly an
entire year on planning what you are
going to do leaving us with only three
years remaining to to see anything that
you're actually going to get anything
concrete done thank
you uh thank thank you councelor Wally
hoggins uh councelor Harvey please thank
you
chairperson um the structure of this
plan is little different from the
previous administration's plan our plan
set out five objectives this plan sets
out six objectives in Broad measure they
are arguably not dissimilar in intent
there are evidently differences in the
emphasis that this Administration wishes
to bring to the way it manages the
council Affairs and I make no bones
about that but there are two Stark
differences between this plan and its
predecessors to which I'd like to draw
attention the first is that the previous
administration committed itself to
deliver and I quote a sustainable
medium-term financial plan by 2023 and
enable the council to be less dependent
on central government
financing we took the decisions
necessary to ensure that we did deliver
Financial sustainability but the plan on
offer here does not commit the new
Administration to similar Financial
sustainability the second difference is
the commitment the previous
administration made to the adoption of a
new core strategy for the district prior
to July 2016 the council ended up with
planning applications it couldn't
effectively resist and developments in
locations it didn't want it's all the
more surprising therefore that the plan
now before us makes no reference to any
priority for the count not finding
itself in the same position it was prior
to
2016 the previous administration made
considerable progress towards the
creation of a new core strategy for
South warshire it allocated resources
for this purpose and made significant
amount of progress towards this end the
sounds now the signs now are not good
the new Administration has laudable
aspirations to increase the supply of
affordable housing something the
previous administration delivered on in
record numbers the new Administration
shares our environmental sensitivities
where the current green belt is
concerned any new core strategy will
have to try and square circles like this
areas like saam wellsborne and shipston
have already taken the line share of new
development in the district the new
Administration is going to have to take
some difficult and controversial
decisions over the next 3 and a half
years on where development in the future
will take place
and I'm afraid that experience shows
that when faced with a difficult
decision such as the decision over the
new green green waste scheme that now
generates more than2 million pound of
Revenue to the council liberal Democrats
failed the test despite some of our of
its laudable and shared aspirations this
plan is fundamentally flawed it lacks
focus on the essentials that the council
can affect it does control and for which
it does have responsibility it seeks to
deliver in too many areas for which it
does not have the responsibility and
with the resources it doesn't possess it
seeks to commit energy and time to
influencing others whilst living in Hope
rather than understanding the confines
of its own responsibilities and
delivering on them to conclude I quote
one resident to the public consultation
who rather summed it all up in a single
sentence
quote a vision needs a strategy which is
action related otherwise it's totally
meaningless and reads like a wish list
that may seem harsh shair person but
it's not a million miles away from the
truth thank you counselor any other
member wish to speak on
this yes councelor
Crum thank you um just very briefly I
noticed in in the response to um I think
lady was called Jane price from I spoke
here the idea of a citiz assembly is
interesting I'm happy to consider this
as we develop our ongoing public
engagement um just looking at the
respondents to the profile of
respondents um only eight towns and
Parish councils responded and I assume
they were probably not likely to be in
the east of the district um we had 21 on
behalf of the business and 18 on behalf
of voluntary and Community groups and
I'll imagine we've had significant
amount of people respond to this um so
it would be interesting to see uh how
this is developed and particularly um
engaging with residents in the east of
the district which I think the deputy
leader acknowledged at the cabinet that
there could be some improvement so I
look forward to that especially in South
and EAS of the district thank
you thank you councelor councelor
Crowther
please
thank you very much indeed chair several
mentions have been made about core
strategies and local plans um I have to
remind the council that uh this Council
was in chaos in 2016 because we did not
have a local planning process I believe
the conservatives were in control at
that time core strategy was produced
very good document uh and that remains
in place and is entirely current at this
time uh all of the components in the
core strategy are still current and will
be for the foreseeable future um and
clearly obviously in our in our um in
our in our in our strategy going forward
clearly we are reviewing the local plan
we're having to review it because this
government which we have at the moment
is totally unclear about where we're
going with with with planning going
going forward and we know that there's
going to be a new local plan scheme
coming forward next year and I'm really
very keen that this Council does not
waste a lot of time uh on on uh on
strategizing when we are going to be
overruled by a government uh which may
or may not still be in place uh dur
during NE during next year the
importance that we have in relation to
this is to make sure that we have got
coherent planning policies going forward
we have that with the core strategy at
the moment and we will in due course
working with our partners in war
District also have a coherent and good
plan which will emphasize some of the
more important things that we have which
have been completely ignored by the
previous administration lack of
infrastructure which is which is a major
problem throughout the district and a
much greater emphasis on carbon
reduction and the green agenda which is
so important for us thank
you thank you councelor do any of the
members wish to
speak okay councelor rock
please uh thank you very much chair um
I'm not going to go over the same ground
that's uh been uh spoken of before um I
ju I just would point and uh councelor
Crump was there when this was discussed
at the cabinet and as he correctly
points out uh it was discussed and I I
did raise concern about um how we could
engage with communities across the
district and in fact that that did
allude to the question from the public
um and uh
I think you know in that particular
context we have lots of community groups
involved with environment there and I
think we can we we can can we can deal
with that in some of those citizens
assemblies uh or that type of thing that
the leader was alluding to in in
response to that question so I think
that engagement is something we can work
on uh Council of Harvey
criticizes uh the plan for uh its desire
to engage more closely with Partners now
we've got to be realistic here we're add
district council with fairly constrained
scope as to our levels of
responsibility and unless we're going to
work closely with other authorities it's
going to be difficult to achieve
positive aims to make a difference to
people's lives so I would defend that
desire to work with other uh with other
authorities and other bodies to to deal
with that so um I think um we're
criticized for two month
delay uh compared with previous
administrations that have been in place
for many years more than 20 years well
people will make their judgment I don't
think that's too bad thank you very
much thank you councilor AR um I have a
second and I I have a proposer and I
have a seconder can I have a show of
hands please for all in
favor are you in
favor
okay
all those against
please and abstains
please carried that's carried thank you
very
much um item 12 on the agenda please is
the agenda of the minute from the
cabinet meeting regarding the South
warshire Economic Development strategy
and action plan can I please call upon
councel
coucher to introduce this
report thank you chair um there is a
recommendation to this Council and I'll
just read it out um that the South
warshire Economic Development strategy
and action plan for
2024 to 25 be adopted with
implementation commencing 1st of April
2024 subject to adoption by both
Stratford and War district councils and
that two that subject to recommendation
one Authority be delegated to the head
of development in consultation with the
planning and economic development
portfolio holder to make any minor
changes prior to publication of the
South warshire Economic Development
strategy and action plan for
2425 and to oversee the annual review of
the action plan and monitoring of the
implementation in accordance with the
council's corporate plan economic
priorities um this is a very important
document uh for this Authority our
economy is extremely precious it is what
creates the jobs for local people it is
what generates the wealth um that
ensures the well-being of our
district uh I pay tribute to Mark won
and the economic development team who
have put the plan together uh which is
has been a thorough review of what we
have done done to date uh there is
considerable amount of continuity in the
plan from uh what was there previously
because business likes certainty it
likes continuity and that's extremely
important uh but it also uh has uh new
emphasis for this Authority it has three
deliberate um tar uh uh titles for it
people productivity and place people are
our most um valuable asset within the
district and ensuring that we are
developing uh the workers of the future
is extremely important for us
productivity also extremely important it
is the way in which we generate
additional wealth uh given uh a fixed
state of of resources and obviously
place also extremely important but here
there will be considerable overlap with
the local plan which we're putting
together at the
moment um
one of the things which there is within
the uh report which I know is very
important to certain parishes which have
been lobbying me about it is the whole
question of infrastructure you cannot
have economic growth if you do not
provide the infrastructure to go
alongside it so roads are really
important uh education facilities are
really important and the welfare Leisure
and health of our Workforce also
extremely important so we have got to
have proper infrastructure much of which
we can't provide as an authority but we
have to lobby and encourage others to do
so um there is also I know very much of
great uh interest to our green
colleagues uh also a much greater
emphasis on carbon reduction and
ensuring that uh our uh economic
development in this district is
sustainable for the future um and uh we
move hopefully closer and closer closer
to zero carbon um during uh during this
period uh which the plan covers so I
would endorse it to the council hope
that the policy is
adopted thank you councelor C chair um
can I have a second that
please um I I'd be very happy to Second
this item and I reserve my right to
speak at the end thank
you thank you councelor Holmes um
are there any members who wish to speak
on this matter please uh councelor
Parry thank you Madame
chairperson as the previous portfolio
holder for economic development I shall
of course be supporting the economic
development strategy this very very
important document and development of it
was actually developed by the
conservative Administration and launched
at the driving Innovation and growth
Summit in February earlier this year
this event was also our
brainchild conceived in June
2022 and developed in close
collaboration with the Coventry and
warshire growth Hub to provide the
platform to launch this strategy and its
focus on generating inward investment
and expansion from new and existing
high-tech Innovative Enterprises which
also gained extensive media coverage 10
months ago a six week's consultation
followed and a few tweaks have
subsequently been made in particular to
further emphasize the role that tourism
provides to both districts otherwise it
is essentially the same document
launched back in February so of course I
shall be supporting it in view of the
importance of generating economic growth
across our districts I am just a little
surprised that it has taken longer to
make the final amendments to this
document than it did to write the public
consultation document in the first place
as a member of cabinet in the previous
administration the role of the leader
and cabinet to drive projects and make
decisions and not by sitting in the slow
lane and allowing key strategic
initiatives to drift like this one and
others such as the South warshire local
plan thank you
chairperson thank you counselor uh
councelor Parker
please thank you chair and uh thank you
councelor coucher for bringing this
forward um probably no surprise to any
in this room that um have some concern
about this um this new proposal being
brought forward uh including the a46
expressway this appears to be in
contradiction with the climate change uh
emergency that is acknowledged by this
Council I understand that improvements
to the road are seriously required for
safety but since this is a new proposal
since the last plan I think we would
welcome uh a period of consultation on
this so we can better understand what it
means and what can be done to mitigate
the D dages that it will cause with more
traffic coming onto the roads and the
pollution associated with it thank
you thank you councelor Parker any of
members wish to speak on this
please thank you councelor passing
out um yeah I'd like to uh well welcome
the uh the paper that c councelor CER
has submitted just before the uh meeting
in which he states that um the rail
travel was also noted as an area for
future sport this is subsequent to a
discussion that was had at cabinet um
and and really the the document does
have some very good words about more
active travel and less traffic on the
roads and the best way of achieving this
and the the only way we can really get
modal change get people to move out of
their cars is to improve the rail system
and in particular for Stratford um
reinstating the rail link between
Stratford and
longm partic and especially if there's
going to be any more development on the
longm Airfield and on on a the ideal
Brownfield site in the district really
so yeah welcome very much that in the
future they'll be including iuson of
better rail systems for
statford thank you councelor any other
members who wish to speak
please then as a final to speak on it
councelor Holmes
please thank you chair um as our
short-term government makes only
short-term decisions at the expense of
residents across the district it's
fantastic to see that the council is now
focused on supporting the district's
strong economy um and are determined to
sustain and accelerate this forward this
policy document shows the new council's
commitment to make infrastructure and
environment priorities for the district
areas the previous administration had
severely lacked I'm rather surprised to
hear about the conservative colleagues
also talking about economic growth um
when when in recent memory their their
colleagues were responsible for crashing
the economy um so so in a whole I wholly
uh support this this policy document I
hope my colleagues do
too councelor Wally hogins
please can I remind Council Holmes that
this is the district council it deals
with District Council matters nothing to
do with well not always to do with
central government but shortly according
to this agenda we'll be bringing up
matters that the central government is
having an impact
on this Council so for those of you that
were frowning when you thought that we
were talking about uh the the
implementation of economic development
plan uh while we were in the in
administration here's the document here
here's the proof that we were the ones
that wrote it and initiated it and I
thank councelor Parry for having the
insight for doing just that because
without it I doubt very much that this
Administration would have been able to
write such a thing in such a well I
could say short space of time but as it
is seven months since they took up
office uh there we go thank
you thank you thank you counselor um any
other members wish to speak
please right I have a proposer and I
have a seconder can I have a show of
hands please all in
favor thank you
members okay okay item 13 on the agenda
a growing opportunities plan 2023
2025 um this was sorry excuse me um from
the cabinet meeting on the 4th of
December oh have I just done that one no
no sorry I had a moment there um
councelor juned can I ask you please to
introduce this
report yes I'm I'm very glad to to be
able to introduce this report uh we are
committ commed to ensuring that our
communities are given access to as many
opportunities as possible and that does
require being able to work in
Partnerships with a whole range of
people uh including the County Council
including the uh voluntary or sector all
the people that are are listed in this
uh strategy uh on page
202 uh have worked together on this
strategy over quite a while and I am
happy to be able to uh endorse what they
have come up with
um there have been two statford onav
social inclusion statements in the past
with Associated uh action plans this was
uh this will take us the next step on
and it's recommended that we support the
work of the the organizations and the
communities that were involved in this
uh and uh I propose that we second we
propose that we accept um this strategy
which has also been um endorsed by the
the leader of the County Council thank
you
thank you uh leader can I have a second
uh please councilor
rol um yes I second this and I would
quite like to speak now if that's
possible please
do um councilor Rock mentioned earlier
about the importance of partnership
working um and
um I think there's even more reason for
that than ever before um because despite
what some people think in this chamber
um um central government have a huge
effect on the people in this District um
and the huge
cutbacks um has resulted in more food
bank referrals more more referrals from
citizens advice uh more referrals from
act on energy social prescribers I could
go on I could go on and on and on and I
would suggest on page
210 when it looks at uh the most
deprived areas um and that's n
2019 I supect when we see the next
report um there'll be even more listed
on that report so yes I do um I do truly
believe that working together um is very
important and it's all about the people
that we are working for it's not about
pretty diagrams and pages of um of
charts Etc is actually getting down to
Grassroots level and helping the people
that need our support in these very very
difficult times thank
you thank you councelor Ralph um are
there any of the members who wish to
speak on this matter
please councelor Wally hoggins
please um much of this report is to do
with the uh Central government's
leveling up strategy so therefore the
conservative group are heartened indeed
that as a result of the conservative
government's leveling up program that
the lib Dems have in fact managed to
Galvanize themselves into uh doing
something whilst working with the wari
County Council have also been working
very hard with this thank
you thank you councelor councelor Jenny
fagley please thank ch um I'd just like
to say I mean from the discussion so far
in in other debates it's crucially
important that we actually manage to
work with all our partners in able to
actually move the condition of our
residents forward because our real
responsibility in the distri district is
the people who live in this District but
we can't improve their their
opportunities without working with uh
our partners and one of the particular
opportunities that I have real concern
about is transport that people from the
rural areas and the rural towns can
manage to move to where jobs and
opportunities are and that is a key
responsibility between district and
County and I hope that relationship will
grow deepen and actually be bring the
investment that we need to our local
Transport Systems be it cycling walking
um buses and actually cars come at the
bottom of that list thank
you thank you councelor
fragile
sorry councelor Crump please thank you
thank you chairperson yeah this is yes I
remember this came to um cabinet and I
was there from OC there's a couple of
points on this is to do with breaking
down these areas on the map of um
deprivation because there will be some
smaller areas that are not pertinent to
that you you might have a area that's
looking really good on the map is with
least areas of deprivation but a part of
that there will be some Pockets so again
we need to look into that and we require
all counselors to do that and offices as
well so I think that was one point we
need to emphasize fact that osc we've
had citizens advice Bureau come to a
task and venage group uh and we've asked
um for another report in three months
time to to look at this deprivation and
what areas they would recommend as well
so we think that is important involving
partners and this is where we have to
involve our partners and I definitely
agree
definitely agree with Council Rock on
that one so um please can we just look
at the pockets of deprivation also look
at what citizens advice are saying and
take some of their advice as well so
it's in the name so it does make sense
um so I think and osc will be looking at
this to make sure we are meeting um our
obligations we are doing what it says on
the tin and we are also making sure we
are meeting the residents who really
need it and as we said there are pockets
of deprivation and we all know there are
one or two people who are running below
the radar we you suddenly come become
aware of them and you just wonder why
those people haven't had the help over a
number of years so we've got to get to
those people are difficult to reach so
um so thank you I will be supporting
this thank
you thank you councelor Kump uh
councelor vo
please yes at the risk of constantly
agreeing with councelor Crump which is a
really worri
uh but I do think he's probably picked
up what I said at cabinet about super
output areas that they
are they can be quite misleading because
of the pockets of deprivation and
particularly in rural areas where it
there's low population and it swipes
across it I think we but it's a question
what we do with it it's a question how
we deal with it and I think all of us in
this room we know we we will get
feedback from individuals with problems
wherever we are whether we're in in
Stratford town in where these these red
marks come up here or when we're in the
rural areas it's as talk us to deal with
those individuals but Council C is
absolutely right that this can disguise
these pockets of deprivation and I think
we need to be alert to that with with
our actions thank
you thank you councelor B uh councelor
Jun yes in um in proposing this um it is
it was with the understanding looking at
the statistics that were in the council
plan and the statistics that are in this
plan how much
worse everything is within this District
the number of the amount of poverty as
councelor Rolph um also indicated the
amount of people using food banks but
the amount of poverty overall the amount
of children the number of children that
are living in low-income households the
number of other problems that have
Arisen within the last three four five
years since the last lot of figures it
is not something that I relish that
should we should be able to say about
this District that that people are worse
off now than they were three to four
years ago H and we have to do something
about that when you see that 11% of our
children that is
2544 of our children are living in
low-income families that there is in
2021 and that is not not yet been
updated there were
9,464 that is 16% of all households
living in fuel poverty it is not
something to be proud of it is something
to be addressed so I hope you will
accept this partnership um document
going forward thank
you thank you leader do any other
members wish to speak on this
matter well I have a proposer I have a
second there can I um see a show of
hands all in favor of this please
that's carried thank you very
much um it te item 14 has actually been
um
withdrawn so no need to go on to that
one so we're on to item 15 please
counselor's
questions we've received four questions
and the answers have been received and
circulated not yet hang on um to on a
separate
cheet
um yes Council of
hton sorry about that a little technical
difficulty there um I'm sorry
chairperson I am a simple broie boy um
and I'm a little slower on the upt U I'm
just not not sure how a minute can be
withdrawn from the papers I just would
be grateful just for some clarification
if I of course I beg your pardon members
yes I'll ask Council Mr Alon again um
David going to explain thank you hello
Darren hello to councelor um as I
mentioned in the announcements earlier
on the agenda councelor item 14 has been
withdrawn as initially there was
expected to be a a decision coming from
the audit and stands committee to
council today that isn't audit sen
resolved on all of those items the
minutes from that meeting will now go to
the meeting in February thank
you is that okay councelor
pton right item 15 councilor's
questions
um councelor one councelor Harvey do you
have a
supplementary thank you chairperson I
think that's the first time I've been
refer to as counselor one thank thank
you for that
um indeed uh can I thank councilor
Curtis for the courtesy of his reply to
what I think is a potentially serious
matter but could I be assured that the
leader will ensure that the portfolio
holder for resources will make it his
business to monitor the financial
position of War District Council and
this Council will be advised in full
time accordingly
please councilor Curtis would you like
to respond to that please yes uh thank
you Council Harvey for your written
question the very helpful context
therein and also if your informal press
cutting service which you uh under take
for me that's most helpful um as
outlined in my reply um yes the our
section1 officer Mr Burl does have
confidence in his counterpart at
District coun at War District Council
and they do have regular
meetings um partly in expectation of the
council's merger which was abandoned As
We Know by the previous administration
there are several joint working areas
between the two councils uh legal Refuge
contract and
ND policy work for the SLP and
governance
manager as that merger is no longer
taking place we are looking at how we
should be revising the existing section
113 agreement between the two councils
and it has been raised that there are
areas that we do need to to look at more
carefully um so I I I take your your
point very very seriously and we will
ensure that uh we do monitor the
situation at War District Council and as
Mr B pointed out with all of our other
contract
Partners it is of course unfortunate
that so many local authorities are
facing uh financial problems at the
moment the latest report by the lgu
estimated that perhaps one in six could
be in danger of issuing section 114
notices but again picking up Council
rol's Point earlier on that's really
hardly
surprising when central government
funding to local authorities has been
cut by 50% over the last 10
years I do respect councelor Harvey and
and his colleagues but if they really
wish to see Improvement in local
government
finances enabling us to deliver better
Services particularly for the those most
vulnerable in our
communities they can make a difference
at the next general election thank you
councelor sorry question two and three
uh councelor bromage isn't present today
uh so question four uh councilor
strander do you have a supplementary
question please
thank you chair no I do not have a
supplementary question thank you very
much um item 16 questions to the
leader please I allow 30 minutes for uh
questions with each counselor being
whoa just keep them up at please for a
few minutes uh no more than three
minutes per question please and no more
than two questions uh councelor pton
please thank you chairperson and uh
thank you for your forbearance in
permitting me the opportunity to ask the
first question uh for the benefit of
other members that comes off the back of
uh a motion that I and councelor shenton
were looking to bring forward to uh to
to this council meeting um just to set
the the context uh for the question to
the leader for for for other members um
warshire fire and rescue Service uh has
started today to embark on a
consultation exercise that runs until
March the thir um to look at
reconfiguring uh Fire and Rescue
Services across warshire as a whole um
to meet what it sees as the changing
demands uh on its uh on its services um
residents in affected communities are
already galvanizing themselves to
respond to the consultation and while
this local work is vital um The District
Council can and should take a strategic
view about the implications of this uh
consultation for all residents across
the district so my question to the
leader and chair person I do have a a
second question if I may after this uh
the my question to the chair is uh to
the leader is uh will will councelor
junid the leader um confirm that the
chief executive will be directed to
ensure that an appropriate and robust
response to the consultation is prepared
and submitted with input from relevant
officers covering Community safety
planning policy economic strategy health
and well-being and housing in response
to the consultation and moreover will
the leader commit that um members who
have a fire station within their Ward uh
will also be consulted on the uh
preparation of the district council's
response to this vitally important issue
for all of our residents uh I just seek
your confirmation on both those points
lader thank you um unfortunately you
were you missed uh my introduction right
at the very beginning uh because at the
in in in the introduction I actually
said that um the consultation had been
um issued and that I've already
expressed my wish that wari County
Council fire service officers should be
invited to an overview and scrutiny or
other committee here to brief counselors
to make sure that we all have the
relevant all the complete and relevant
information and I'm happy to include uh
whoever else will would needs to have
that information we need full full
information and then we need to be able
to give a robust consultation and I am
one of those that is covered by a fire
uh service that's fire station and um
not only am I covered by a particular
fire station but it is a fire station
where there was a very unfortunate loss
of four people as a result of of a fire
so we in oler feel very very strongly
about the consultation as I'm sure
others who have fire stations in their
area do so I've already asked that that
that we invite the officers to make sure
um that we understand and that we can
give our robust um views to the County
Council fire
service thank you leader and I I thank
you for your response and I would
probably observe that's the the downside
of being fashionably
late if I may I a second question I
think I'm allowed a second question um
um Council coucher uh extoled the
importance of the uh emerging South
warshire local plan which does kind of
reinforce the the the point that it
actually should be referenced in the
council plan but I have a question
around the the the emerging South
workshire local plan in in in a couple
of parts I wonder if the leader would be
able to confirm um that the then
planning policy portfolio holder um
engaged the Met Office in terms of
supporting the work on the south Ora
local plan uh to ensure that the plan uh
does have climate change at its heart uh
I would be grateful if you would confirm
that that is the case um secondly that
you can confirm that uh uh throughout
the entire process the uh the notion of
climate change being at the heart of the
emerging SA local plan has been
inculcated from day one uh so it is not
really true to say that this is a new a
change in emphasis uh and indeed the
leader will recall that uh she and I had
a debate about whether we move through
an SPD uh for uh improving our approach
to environmental matters uh versus
actually going going large on the local
plan itself uh we did in in fact I was
persuaded that an SPD uh sorry
development document was approach but
only as an interim step towards the
local plan which will be as I have said
on many occasions before uh the May
election the local plan is the key
policy driver that this organization has
in um driving our response to the
climate emergency so I'd just be
grateful for confirmation on the the
question of the golden thread and uh the
Met
Office uh I'm not sure coun um councel
ccher might be able to say more about
the Met Office but I and understand that
it is they are still being consulted and
and and involved um but uh on the
climate change it's a matter of degree I
want it to go much further much far
farther much faster because one of the
things that uh we have found for example
had people been able to have um the
original level of insulation put into
their homes as was envisaged in 2015 to
be inut in uh put in place in 2016 for
develop M of and Housing Development had
that put in been put in place at that
time and had we not been still waiting
for that that carbon zero house
consultation to come from government an
awful lot of people would have found
their energy bills much much much
reduced over this last winter and the
winter to come so I need to we need to
be able to make sure that PE that the
climate change and all the benefits that
come from addressing aspects of climate
change are fully involved and fully
developed in the local plan and that is
one thing that I am committed to it is
something I've spent 30 years of my
professional life doing and I am
committed to that thank
you thank you for the answer leer just
before I go on to the next question
David chairman thank you I've never seen
so many hands go up so quickly at the
beginning of the debate and therefore I
don't think I've absolutely captured
everybody to help chairman if if if you
did have your hand up at the beginning
and I don't call your name out now could
you could you could you put your raise
your hand again please councelor Linda
Oran councelor Olivia hatch councelor
Dave passam Tom Holmes Stuart Keithley
Lewis Adam MW were there any further
with okay sorry Kate there was so
many so we got councelor Kate Hardin I
FR Susan aanda thank
you okay thank you for that councelors
it was very difficult to see everybody
all at one time uh councelor Linda Oran
please thank you chairperson regarding
the question from councelor bromich in
councelor questions would the leader be
prepared to remind councelor bromage
that the decision to dispose of the
Grange in saam was not taken by the
previous administration but by the
20159 administration on the 10th of
September
2018 when I was the portfolio holder for
finance and physical
resources that minute T 94 of that
meeting of the cabinet included the
following
words whilst the portfolio holder noted
the requests that proceeds of the sale
be reinvested back into saam it was
recognized that was not how the capital
program
worked however cabinet were open to
receiving suggestions from saam which
could be considered alongside the the
budget
process and would the leader be prepared
to ask councilor bromich to
unconditionally withdraw his unfound
assertion that there was any
understanding or undertaken given
contrary to the terms of minute 294
thank
you I I shall ask for a guidance on this
on legal guidance on this one but um I
understand I don't think anybody should
um give untoward um accusations I I
understand that um some it would there's
some implications in there that really
ought to be addressed um I think we will
have a word with Council
bromich thank you leader councelor
Holmes
please hello um thank you chair my
question was around the peer the
planning peer um review challenge uh
that's been undertaken taken um I
believe it's been completed as uh uh
would like to know idea of when it will
be available to members the results of
it and also importantly to the public
thank
you I understand it the detail is still
being finalized uh but hopefully uh in
the new year it will be made available
we do need to know um the detail of that
and they U perhaps you can speak to the
portfolio holder councelor C cure after
the meeting thank you
thank you uh councelor Stuart night
Keithley
please oh thank you chair
um right this is a a question around uh
transport and infrastructure transport
of people and goods and
services um we've already heard through
the items we've been debating
um about some of the issues um my friend
a member from for tredington in item 11
mentioned that there would been
record-breaking amounts of development
and you mentioned shipston and and
wellsborne um in my ward long maren
we've also got a lot of development lots
of new houses um lots of new people and
my friend the M for shipston recognized
this when we talked about I item 12 and
he mentioned that uh he would like to
see um the rail reinstated so we could
have a Stratford to Paddington
Express um great um my question is
around the transportation studies that
we are awaiting that have been um put
together by warshire and Stratford
District now there's a a huge increase
in traffic for everybody living south of
the river and you probably if you
traveled in that direction recently
you'll notice it particularly because
the wford bridge is closed and we've
also had a very busy town center so with
all these new houses and development
south of the river we're getting a lot
of frustration people are waiting a lot
in traffic cues it's got an impact on
air quality um and and people are
finding it really difficult to move
around now about uh two years ago we
part funded some important transport
studies which were looking at
sustainable
alternatives for travel to and from the
Airfield Village and these new
developments um now I understand that
these transport studies are with
officers and there are three that we're
waiting on um some of the decisions on
development south of the river are
waiting on the information from these
transport studies could I ask the leader
please to advise whether or not these
studies will be released soon so we can
start to see um how we're going to
manage the impact of all this additional
development south of the river
particularly and the surrounding
Villages and will these studies provide
us with the information that we need to
start to consider our transport strategy
going forward thank you yes the um the
two vectos reports um were um were
commissioned by The District Council and
the and the County Council together I
believe that um the outcome of that um
was not satisfactory to the county so
they they H they did a separate study
called the Jacobs study the vector
studies are complete uh but it was
agreed that they will be published
alongside the the Jacobs uh study which
was the one that was commissioned by
wari County Council officers have
received an initial uh draft but they're
providing feedback to the Jacobs uh
report um they they do need to get some
in and get some response back from
questions that they're asking of that
report um the questions that they from
when I asked the officer they said that
once the draft is finalized it will be
shared with the district council and
County Council or counselors uh I do
hope that that is sooner rather than
later because it don't we do need to be
able to progress on this and it it is um
I think if we' gone with just the vectos
report we would have had it all by now
but because of the delay with the caused
by having to commission the Jacobs
report it has taken a longer time I have
asked the officers to keep me updated
and make sure that I and the portfolio
holder are given um a timetable for when
these will be progressed I would hope
that they're in the New Year in the
beginning of the new year
thank okay thank you uh ler if I can
just ask members to keep their questions
shorter so I can try to get everybody in
because I'm going to struggle otherwise
um Lewis Adams
please thank you chair um parish and
town councils have a rightful uh
responsibility to be a statutary consult
to most panning applications uh giving
them the ability to call items to
Committee in in in the interest of
maintaining a high standard of
Engagement uh in this regard and to
encourage ongoing consultation across
the district um is the council willing
to provide training to parish and town
councils as the local planning authority
to ensure they are up to date on the
planning processes and any relevant
recent updates in this area thank you um
thank you it is something I've already
asked I've already asked whether um
Parish councils could be included in the
training that is given to counselors for
example um I think it is we would take
it away because I think it's a very very
relevant question H and we do need to
make sure that um that everybody is
trained not only on our own local plan
and the district council what the
district council could do but for
example and anything to do with
neighborhood development plans as well
so I would happy to take that away and
ask the qu question thank
you thank you leader uh councelor
perella
please thank you chair as the leader
mentioned in their announcements and
councelor pton touch upon just now
warell County Council is proposing
radical changes to our local fire and
rescue service provision from unle
stations to a surge team model untested
in a comparable rural County and so
residents are very concerned about what
is proposed and an impact on a rural
District in relation to fires flooding
and car accidents so I would add to what
councelor pton said that all members of
this Council are consulted on any formal
response from straford District Council
to the consultation because we might not
have a fire station in our W but we rely
for our safe safety on our neighbors so
if that could be done um thank you lead
chair yeah just responding to the
previous answer yes I'm happy to for
that to be done thank
you thank you uh thank you for that uh
councelor hatch
please um I wondered if there was any
move to digitalize um meeting
literature um I suggest that if people
really do want a paper copy they have to
opt in it and have to pick it up from
the council offices saving on paper and
postage
costs um some committees already the
climate change panel already does uh
have um paperless I think we have to uh
look at this in the round because some
people do have difficulty for example
with eyesight problems and there
something we need to to look at very
very carefully um I do take your point
though that um we do need to reduce the
amount of paper that's being printed and
and sent out so uh it's something we I
think we are moving towards I think
nationally across councils and across
government um but I think I do think we
we do need to take into account uh for
example I I have one one eye that
doesn't work in properly um and um I I
do find sometimes
um information on screen is difficult to
read so I think we do have to take a
balanced view but it is it is the way
that things are going and the climate
change panel already does uh has already
reduced its paper and doesn't send out
paper paper
agendas thank you leader uh councelor
passingham
please yeah um councelor junid announced
a few weeks ago if not two or three
months ago that there would be a climate
change fund of 00 th £100,000 for the
community and uh obviously welcome that
but there doesn't seem to be in a launch
it's not available yet could you tell us
when it's when it'll be
available um yes I asked exactly the
same question it is going through the
legal process that and it will be
launched in the new year and then
communities will be able to apply for
it and in the New Year means
January
thank you uh leader uh councelor Kate
wal
please uh thank you chair um would the
leader agree that members need to be as
accurate as possible when making
statements in this
chamber at the last four council meeting
on the 16th of October
2023 at around 51 minutes and 20 seconds
in councelor Parry stated that when
voting for or against adopting the core
strategy the lib Dems either abstained
or voted against the core
strategy may I please point out the
following that on the 11th of July
2016 at the full council meeting Council
gitis seconded by councelor Perry asked
for a recorded vote when considering dur
ing the adoption of the core
strategy councilors Hazel Wright Peter
Moss Jenny fragle and myself all voted
in favor of the adoption of the core
strategy and in fact two members of the
conservative group voted against that
was councelor Mills and councelor
chares would the leader agree in such
circumstances that it would be
appropriate for this to be corrected and
for C coun Parry to apologize for giving
out incorrect
information perhaps you could follow
this up thank
you I I also went back and checked
because I wasn't sure not being a
counselor at the time there were
actually seven sets of recorded votes
and in each of the seven sets of
recorded votes um the the the the four
liberal Democrats all favored all voted
in favor uh and so I I was going to you
know if councelor rol hadn't raised it I
was going to raise it because we do need
to be accurate uh and I I would hope
that um councilor par would accept that
um the the minutes are accurate that we
all the liberal Democrats at that time
all voted for uh the last Co core
strategy and and I really do think that
sometimes you know using this kind of
you know these kind of inaccuracies
actually brings local government into
disres repute thank you
thank you uh councelor Roger Harding
please thank you chair uh we recently
saw the effect of a young man being
pursued by the police attempting a
handbrake turn on clopton bridge and
demolishing part of the parit for a
while the bridge was closed entirely and
for bit longer it was closed in one lane
only which had pretty serious effects on
the traffic around the
town we had the Easter 98 floods we had
the floods of 2007 when the water levels
again Rose to within a meter of the top
of the
Arches recently we've seen Bridges
pretty much like clopton Bridge medieval
Bridges Swept Away in Germany from
flooding from climate change and it's
not going to get any
better so could I ask the leader to
request a report back on what
contingency plans are in place in the
event of a long-term damage to the
bridge closure to the bridge and in
particular what traffic modeling has
been carried out to see where displaced
25,000 Vehicles a day will go bearing in
mind that seven Meadows bridge is
already carrying 16,000 Vehicles a day
councelor this is a County council issue
could I please request this rais with
the County Council it's both County
Council and District we have an
emergency plans unit here as
well the district council also takes
part in emergency planning uh and also
there is um there is our planning uh
document as well that has to look at
some some of the impact of Transport Etc
but it is a a County council issue as
well we do need to make sure that uh as
as representatives of the residents of
statford on Aven in particular uh that
we make sure that um clopton bridge is
is properly the the plans and um any any
uh issues that you mentioned are
properly taken up um so it is a County
Council matter there are many people
here in this count in this um Council
chamber who are also County counselors I
would urge them also to take this up
with the County Council and I'm sure it
already has been done counselor roolf
I'm sure will have done because it's in
her Ward and she will have taken that up
but we do need to make sure that all
counselors are kept informed uh of what
is what the County Council is saying on
that
matter councelor rol has has responded
that she will report
back thank you councelor in fragile
please thank you chair some years ago
there were around 10 to 12 cycle racks
on the island at the top of Bridge
Street opposite W Smiths
these were removed to accommodate an
event on Bridge Street after the event
only half of the cycle racks were
restored now that the last weekend's
event is finished please could I ask
that the original 10 to 12 cyc racks are
restored rather than just five thank you
I am happy to ask the relevant portfolio
holder to take that up with the officer
to make sure that that that is
done
uh councelor asan
please thank you chair this is a
question that relates to hs2 as a ward
member for the Eastern area of the
district I'm aware that hs2 has caused
considerable disruption to this to this
area whilst various grants and funding
sources have been made available to
parish and town councils these have been
restricted in ter in terms in their
terms and often are not straightforward
to access in particular much of the
disruption of hs2 has related to
highways apparently about 8 million
pounds has been given to workshire
County Council in 2017 for spending on
highways and other consequential effects
arising from
hs2 little if any of this money has been
spent my question then is would the
leader approach orire County Council for
the release of these funds to schemes
for the benefit of the residents in the
eastern part of the district pleas
yes the this the this information came
about as a result of a Freedom of
Information um to by often Parish
Council uh to Ora County Council and it
affects the District Council in that it
affects the district councilors but also
uh we need to be aware in our plan local
plan Etc of of some of the the outcomes
um it was 8.04 Million uh that was
driven by the trans department of
transport in 2017 for road safety and
cycle track
um to address the impacts of cycle routs
um and address the impact of hs2 in your
in your area um I asked the County
Council officer to confirm that the
Freedom of Information was accurate and
I was also told that 850,000 has been
spent so far I've asked for more
information and I to the County Council
officers and and I'm happy to liise with
you once I get that uh back um I'm not
sure when the um time table for spending
this was meant to be but it was given
actually received in 2018 although it
was given uh by the dep Department of
Transport in 2017 so it's been with the
County Council since 2018 thank
you thank you L this will be the last
question uh councelor Wally hoggins
please yes I'm I'm somewhat amused by
the volume of uh questions from the
libdem counselors to their leaders who
is the leader of this Council my
question to the leader therefore is do
you actually have regular meetings with
all of your own counselors so that they
can ask questions without taking up
valuable full Council time thank
you not only do we have regular meetings
not only do I have informal meetings
with all of the counselors but I want to
make sure that our counselors can ask in
public about matters that address their
areas and are relevant to their areas
and are important to their areas so that
not only I but the officers of this
Council and officers of other councils
that are looking in and partners of ours
who will be looking in uh will actually
be able to understand that we are car
have have care for much more than just
um the titl tattle that goes on in in in
maybe some group
meetings I have a supplementary question
as a result of there which I do think
you have to Grant to me I okay your
supplementary question then
please so therefore these are not just
um counil questions then this is um also
councelor grand standing is that correct
thank you th this is about important
issues that have been raised by people
residence within people's Wards matters
that are of extreme importance to their
communities For Heaven's Sake we we we
just do not do
grandstanding it it is that is
downgrading the whole idea of democracy
and this council's meeting I I do hope
that um you know perhaps maybe you can
ask some sensible questions okay thank
you um moving on now from counil to the
questions to the leader item 17 notice
of motion
update this is for information only so
please note the the update thank you
councilors item 18 motion to
notice there are two motions un
notice today number one motion for a
declaration of an ecological emergency
in accordance with Council procedure
rules once proposed and seconded the
motion will be referred to the cabinet
for consideration and Report without
debate can I please invite councelor
passingham to propose the
motion yes I would like to propose this
motion um I obviously if anybody watched
uh the planet Earth last night they will
realize what what a grave emergency we
are in as far as the ecology and the
wildlife and the habitats in the whole
world but I think we've denuded out
habitats and Wildlife a long time ago in
this country and it needs restoring so
uh I look forward to the debate in
February when we can actually debate
this
motion thank you
counselor
um I could can I please invite councel
ostranda to uh second the motion please
thank you chair um I'm very happy to
Second this motion when I discovered
that our biodiversity score was Zero I
felt quite alarmed and uh yes wholly
support this motion thank
you thank you counselor uh moving on to
the next motion removal of designated
parking spaces for the chairman of
council the lead of the council and all
other counselors in the chur street car
park in accordance with Council
procedure rules once proposed and
seconded the motion will be referred to
the cabinate for consideration and
Report without debate can I invite
councelor Harvey to propose the motion
please thank you chairperson I propose
the
motion thank you could I please invite
councelor W hogin to second the
motion this is councilor Wy hoggins
seconding this
motion
thank you moving on to item 19 urgent
business there is no urgent
business so there be no further business
at all I'd like to bring this meeting
closed thank
you no but I'll stand up and do that now
is my